Today's topic, right? It seems like the guys from fresh & fit are really upset.
We.
Are better than you.
Period. People want to know our thoughts. I'm gonna keep it really brief. Right?
I don't have much thoughts on their platform.
Are they doing some good things for some people? I'm sure I have no doubt.
I'm not even done great with that.
We just came at them for their ideas, regards to, uh,
paying for box and all this stuff thought it was full of. I'm like,
yo realize don't and for box even more.
What I find really distasteful is you come to find out that Myron Gaines
himself, right? The so-called pick artist,
the master has his own seeking arrangements account, his own profile. All right,
this is on the web. You can find it. This man's out here.
You're talking about don't pay for box. Don't pay for box.
It's on a website for sugar, daddies and sugar babies. Okay. Alright.
You want to be a giant hypocrite?
Do your thing. Okay. Then you come to find out this man's talking about, listen,
if you, we want, we want burning desire from ladies. Ain't that what they say?
Right? You want to get their best. So you gotta earn it.
Come to find out this.
Man's telling girls in the DMS that if they want to come on the platform,
they have to.
And if they don't, he gets upset about it and he gets all pissy. Oh,
you all my other boys. You won't me. Then you can't get on the platform.
So wait,
you want to bang a girl who just wants to come on the platform for clout and you
think that's burning desire. And again, guys,
I don't even that he does goes about that way to bang girls,
do whatever you want. You earned your platform, go ahead,
meet the hypocrisy of these ideas.
You preach to these men that they have to always seek this thing.
That this is the way to live. That this is the best way,
but you don't even walk to talk. That's what I find distasteful.
It's like Derek Jackson talking about be faithful.
Your wife, don't pay for box. Come to out. This man's cheating on everyone.
How are you any different? Can you tell me not everyone's gonna get well,
you know, we're attacking people. The man is, I don't care about the mane.
I don't care about none of this move with integrity in life. That's it.
But not hear about it. Some scene, oh, you can't go on this podcast.
I don't care. At the end of the day, the truth remains the truth.
When I came into the game, when I was listening to Patrice,
we didn't call it red pit. We just called it the truth.
These is front and on some points. That doesn't mean they're not helpful to you.
If you're one of their fans, right? Maybe they help you with finances.
My fitness, maybe even they helped you with game. I don't know.
But all we talked about were these ideas and how they were hypocritical.
Here's the.
Thing. You guys been blowing us up, man. Yeah. You guys,
you guys been blowing us up with DMS apparently. Uh, I've been preach,
excited to make a video, uh, talking smack outta nowhere, outta a left field.
And, and it's funny about captain and, and paying for box. And I was like, Hey,
we talk about this several months ago. Like, why are you guys bringing this up?
Like now? Like what the hell we're trending.
Man. Yeah.
The only reason we brought it up later is cuz we already covered a couple of
videos from that podcast. And the second one after, and this, we,
we did both podcasts on the same day, the first one.
And then I did came back later on for the second one.
I could completely forgot about the first one. So I covered the second one.
And then months later somebody sent me a link to it's like, Hey,
what did you think about this conversation? So I re-watched, it I'm like,
Hey man, there's a lot of dumb things that were said, let me cover it.
It's not that deep. Okay.
This whole idea that there's some giant conspiracy is not that deep.
But anyways, if you guys wanted to know, that was why we're trending.
Man. Yeah. We're popping right now. But then I did as always men lie,
women line numbers. Don't right. And then I thought to myself,
why would they bring this up now? Uh, Chris, can you show exhibit a real fast?
Boom. So let's see here. Uh, they got, let's see,
these guys have almost a million more subs than us guys.
All right. So we're the blue line. We're the blue line. They're the red.
They have 1.38, which is one, 1 million, 380,000 subscribers guys.
They have 430,000 subscribers. Yep. Okay.
We have literally like one less than one third of their joint. Right.
And we got 20 million views and they got 14.9 million views out. Hmm.
Very interesting for you guys to go ahead and make a video consulting us months
after the fact. I wonder why. Oh,
it's because we're hot than you guys right now. All this.
Talk about, we make so much money. We're getting all these views.
These guys are cloud chasing rev. When I came on your podcast,
your podcast was far smaller. I didn't care that you guys were smaller podcasts.
I was like, cool.
Guys. Seem to do some kinda interesting content. I'll just jump on.
I'm not the type of who looks at people and judges their value or their, uh,
perception of me based off of how many followers they have or how many views
they get.
We cover people who are far larger than us who have way bigger platforms.
And we cover people with a hundred subscribers.
We don't come at people based off of the size they following. They have,
we talk about ideas. If you think back about the video.
When we said all that stuff about boxing, this, it was on the topics.
We didn't talk about freshest past. We didn't talk about him.
Faking press releases. We didn't talk about you paying for box. We didn't talk.
None of that. You guys are getting so hyper emotional about this thing.
It's funny to me for so-called alpha males.
You guys don't seem to have any control over your temper, our.
Our channels better than yours. We get more views than you.
We've been on less than you. We work harder than y'all.
We cut our hair more than you like yo, if y'all we get more girls,
get girls than y'all. Like if y'all really, really wanted, preach is married.
Pride to a beluga whale somewhere.
And that talking and how old these think are 40 years old.
Yo, yo all last too, bro. Yo bruh,
I wasn't gonna do this. Wait, the Han symbol. Yo, I was not good.
do this international, but y'all got me hype now. Yo,
I know you guys are not bro.
My ABA looks like he got off a camel. Hasn't cut his hair in years.
<laugh> dusty as. Yo bro.
And this is so Danny roasted on you right now, bro. We, you Somali.
Yo. I was like, yo, what I, you came from bro. Now take a looking BU yourself,
bro, am I you? Right? I don't look on the.
Cause obviously I'm saying that's his though. I we're better than you.
We make more money than you. We got a better channel than y'all.
We get more views than y'all.
The only thing you guys got on us is you guys been on longer,
but I G too next year, this time we're gonna lap you cuz you know what?
Nobody works harder than us. Nope. Period.
We make more money. And, and that the worst part is that I like to,
I like to see, I love to see a black man get paid, get your money.
I've never get your money. If your view are stupid, your views are stupid.
But if you're getting paid, get your money. Yeah. That's not what I'm here for.
There's not a single person that could ever say that we've ever F jealousy or
gotten mad about other people succeeding. We move out our own pace.
Yeah. We've been on the platform long with you. Congratulations to me.
It's not even that deep. You guys are doing well for yourselves. Good for you.
It's great. I ain't never been mad at a making money. This is about the idea.
So all this talk about clout and all this that you guys have lived in Miami so
long and you've been faking your lifestyles for so long that you think everybody
chasing clout, that everybody wants to be with an Instagram bat.
Your whole platform is based around clout chasers.
So that's why your mind is warped. Miami's up.
That's why the girls you bring on. Everyone's like yo,
who are these dumb bros that you bring on? Right? Cuz they're all clout chasers.
So you guys' mindset is all warped and.
It's not like that everywhere around the world. Not everyone is about clout.
If we were cloud,
do you think we'd be covering things like this pandemic and all these other
issues that Deran, our YouTube channel.
It's not about cloud at the end of the day. It's always about integrity.
That's it for us. It's about integrity. Whether we win or we lose money. Y.
Dumb ask with the same entire background, same million plaque.
We got $200,000 plaques now and we're gonna get a million plaque and we're gonna
get the other channel, another mil to a million as well.
And I'm gonna hit a hundred thousand bucks.
We are better than you period. outta here, man.
And we don't pay for.
Bucks. These are the kind of like, you know what? It's like, you know what?
It's like, you know, I love it. That these guys call themselves alpha,
all this other stuff. It makes me laugh. Cuz they got such energies. Crazy.
Yeah.
It's like when you're talking to a girl about a topic. Yeah. You know,
you're talking you, I see this before, you know,
you're talking to your girl about a topic and you guys having a discussion and
she's losing the argument. All of a sudden she start bringing up.
Your Dick is small. Like what does it have to do with economics?
It's like they do the same thing.
I find it so funny that these guys like think they're alpha and 1% man and all
this other stuff. Right? They lack integrity.
They get upset at the most random stuff.
When I was the podcast and they kicked out that girl,
one of the girls beside was like, yo, you're being emotional.
No, but I'll be emotional. I was like, bro, like,
why are you screaming like this?
No wonder these girls come on your podcast and don't respect you.
You don't command, respect. You just yell and get them kicked out.
You think that's alpha behavior.
The idea that you can't even get respect from these ladies is in the indication
of the fact. You don't know what you're doing. It's hyper emotional.
You're just screaming and getting mad. I'm laughing at this cuz it's pathetic.
I don't know what's wrong. But every episode I see you just screaming. Get mad,
screaming out. Ladies,
railroading like women who aren't prepared with all these stats and numbers that
these ladies are like, yo, you would've come on a podcast. Like sure. Uh,
it turns out that 8% of all men,
well how does that have a way to have a discussion? <laugh> just chill.
It's not that deep. I'm like yo.
Real realize don't yo.
Here's the other thing too.
These guys say real as don't pay the box and one's on seeking arrangements.
The other one, the other one is lying about having three girls at one time,
shut the. The other one, you know, shut the up. You know,
you know what kills me about for like, if you listen to him,
you know he has NOCA it's it's painfully obvious. Yeah. That this man, like,
even when you go watch the, the, the, the, the, the vlogs that he does,
he's like, he has this whole thing. Don't lead with money. And like,
in his bunch of his videos, he's like, Hey girl,
I'm gonna shower you with gifts. Come on.
We're gonna go shop for Lambos and Ferrari. I'm like, bro,
if it wasn't for your clout, you wouldn't be out here getting anything.
Let's be real. So I find it so funny, like talk about paying for a box.
You know, I know why this doesn't want to pay for a box. This is his experience.
He went to Columbia with his. Okay. They went to a brothel.
He saw a bad woman. And he's like, oh wow. She is like, come upstairs with me.
He didn't know it was a H house. Cuz this is so lacking. His self-awareness,
you know, he thinks everyone respects him. It's go. Okay.
He gets in and she's like $20. He's like, you want me to pay?
You don't know a who house. When you walk into one, where were you raised?
You not, I don't know how you could be a pickup artist and lack this much.
Self-awareness so he said, I paid the $20.
I banged her and I felt disgusting afterwards.
And that's why I'll never pay for box, bro.
If the first time you eat out is McDonald's burger. And you say,
you hate all restaurants after.
That's not a problem with restaurant restaurants or that's a problem with you.
Problem with your choices. Here's the thing,
the truth about this whole escorting and paying for bucks, CEOs, NBA, players,
princess, all of they all pay for box. They pay for high end escorts.
Why discretion? Expertise. Okay.
I don't care how much your girl loves you and all that other stuff.
If she hasn't studied sex, if she hasn't done all that.
If she hasn't taken the time to really learn, she's not as good as other people.
This whole idea of like, if she has enthusiasm,
you ever been with a girl that's really into you.
And she's using her teeth on your. She got all the enthusiasm in the world.
It's never gonna be a substitute for technique.
The only who are this dumb or N who not had a lot of sex or men who never paid
for good box, even Kevin Samuels will come in and say, I pay for box.
I pay for women to come with me. Kids. He's a real put there. O'Neal for box,
the highest in the game. They pay for box. Not all the time,
but sometimes it's convenient. Uh,
so you want me to tell you not all the time that you working at your middle
class job, you know more about what's being alpha and all this than the CEOs,
the most famous and rich people in the world. Okay. So yeah,
their is beta cuz they pay for box. But you right.
Working at the company as a minimum with age worker, for their company,
you think you know more about what it means to be alpha. Get 'em outta here.
Just don't pay for box. Say it's not for you. It's not for everyone. It's okay.
But paying a hundred dollars for a and then saying it's not as good as a random
girl. I've been on the street. Probably not. You pay for.
Sometimes you get service. You pay, well, you get better service.
It's not these guys talk like they're knowledgeable about this stuff.
And the very people they admire pay for box,
go have this conversation with Kevin. Then go,
go have this conversation with real, go ahead with the NBA players,
the same NBA player that made you, uh, bang three girls on one night, up.
You know, that was so stupid about that story.
This guy bang one wants me to believe he's at a pool party. Okay.
He random pool party. He's at a pool party. This NBA player comes with to him.
He's like, oh, oh my God, man, do you know where the coolest parties are?
He's like, yeah, here, here. Can I, can I have you have your Instagram?
Can I have your Instagram? Oh man. We, we the same girl. Oh my God.
We was in the same bro. I got, I, I got a mansion party tomorrow.
Why don't you come over? And we gonna get it lit. So the guy hold on.
So the guy that.
Was looking for the hottest party happens to have a mansion party the next day,
get the outta here with.
Your Boga. So he needed your help to find a party in town.
But he got a mansion with 50 girls that are rolling through. And let me ask you,
bro, let me ask you in this made up scenario where you're capping the out of
possibilities.
You want me to believe that this man had 50 girls and none of them were paid.
Hmm. You think that these girls that you banged there,
supposedly that you had all three,
but you didn't want a threesome because you wanted to go one at a time cuz you
were too awkward enough. You want me to believe that,
these girls had burning desire for you. Of course not.
They wanted to the NBA player at best. They didn't want to get around with you,
but you think none of these girls are paid. They pay for box. All these guys,
these high value, man. They all pay for box. So man listen. Yes.
Trust what you ever want to trust. Follow, whoever want to follow?
I don't even you're I need to play the rest of the video.
My,
the.